yom l'arrivée vous arrivez tout près
d'eux du maire sortant guy ferrer est ce
que c'est une satisfaction ce score de
40% ce soir pour vous bonsoir bonsoir
j'observe que le candidat socialiste
sortant et moi sommes aujourd'hui au
coude à coude tout est ouvert et donc
très très directement très simplement
j'appelle ce soir toutes les auxerroises
et tous les auxerrois a confirmé
dimanche prochain leur volonté de
changement dimanche prochain je peux
être le nouveau nardos heures on l'a dit
tout à l'heure les clés du scrutin sont
un peu dans les mains de du du front
national du coup pour ce pour ce
deuxième tour est ce que vous allez un
message plus particulièrement pour eux
non les clés du scrutin sont dans les
mains des auxerroises et des auxerrois
vous savez je ne crois pas aux consignes
de vote personne n'est propriétaire de
ses voix au sahara appartient aux
auxerrois personne ne peut dicter leurs
choix aux auxerroises et aux au cerveau